And I was wondering,
out of respect for you,
what would I do?
So at least commission 1 audit from 1 company
independent?
Thank you very much.
So would this solve it
you with 1 audit to 1 company
independent?
And are you 1 political leader who is in charge of this?
How old,
Mr. Monago?
In other words,
do you know that the administration
cannot be audited by private companies?
You don't know? You
does not know.
At this point
you have been President of the Extremadura community.
Anyway,
look,
I shouldn't be doing it that bad either
if everything that comes to mind for you,
if everything that comes to mind for you to improve,
what I am doing
is that it should
commission 1 audit from 1 private company.
Anyway,
eh,
it's not that bad,
I'm not doing it